political ad campaign produced by a
left-wing PAC called American Bridge and
the concept of this ad campaign they've
got a number of ads is Trumpets who
admit it was a mistake to vote for
Donald Trump now I've said before as a
strategy for winning 2024 individual
activists like we are
I don't believe arguing with trumpets to
get them to vote for somebody else is a
good strategy for the left because
number one 62% of Trump is said they
would never question their support for
Donald Trump or reconsider it no matter
what Trump does even hypothetically so
at the get-go with two-thirds of
Trumpets you're simply wasting your
breath but also it takes a lot to
convince someone to change their mind
particularly when they're experiencing
the degree of cognitive dissonance that
so many Trump supporters are so a better
strategy for us at the individual level
is let's get people registered let's get
out the vote from people who already
don't like Trump but to the extent that
maybe disaffected this affected Trumpets
in the 38% who are not committed no
matter what to Donald Trump to the
extent that they might have their minds
changed I actually think that this is a
pretty clever ad campaign for a few
reasons which I'll tell you about in a
moment let's check out the one of these
ads first
my name is mark Graham and I lived in
Erie all my life basically it's a
blue-collar town started off large
manufacturing base lot a lot of water
shipping run running back in the days I
voted for Donald Trump in 2016 because I
thought he would make a change did he
make a change not for the good Donald
Trump only plays favorites for people
like himself not Erie Pennsylvania the
presidents of bullying because it's his
way or no way
he doesn't understand life around here
he thinks he's the smartest person ever
I don't think people believe that
I don't believe Donald Trump is on the
side of American people I think he's on
his own side if I could go back in time
I would tell myself to be aware of the
changes that President Trump has made
voting for Donald Trump in 2020 would be
like putting gasoline on a fire a bee
pack is responsible for the content of
this ad so of course the fact that ads
like these exist is terrible in the
sense that our system is broken
we need money out of politics I hate
PACs I hate all of this ancillary
spending I mean these these are well
produced ads this is not cheap the
airtime is not cheap I've said it a
million times but to the extent that for
the 2020 election this is the game this
is the game of politics in the United
States this is actually pretty clever
there are a lot of Trumpets who won't
vote for someone else because they don't
want to admit to themselves that they
made a mistake they don't want to have
to face others with the fact that they
might abandon Donald Trump because
they're worried about what the reaction
might be ads like these with disaffected
Trumpets who say publicly I'm not voting
Trump again this can serve effectively
like a sort of permission being granted
two trumpets to abandon Donald Trump
because as groupthink might call it that
is effectively what many of these
trumpets are waiting for I am sort of
questioning my vote but unless I get
permission from the group to go
somewhere else in 2020 electoral I'm not
going to do it and when the margin of
victory for Trump ended up being about
77 78,000
votes in three key states including
Pennsylvania where that voter featured
in the ad is from a few ads like these
well produced and broadcast in those key
states could actually be the
difference-maker this is a very
interesting campaign and it's also smart
because it's focusing on rural
working-class voters that's a group that
in a sense propelled Donald Trump to
victory in 2016 in which at least
stereotypically Democrats don't do as
well with in many elections this isn't
so much going after Trump over specific
issues it's it's a general economic
critique but it's not going after Trump
for something specific that he said it's
not related to a Ukraine or impeachment
and that has been a criticism some
people wrote to me saying these ads are
too vague I actually think that that's
good this is a former trumpet who
hopefully is relatable when he says I
made a mistake
I'm not voting for Trump and you don't
have to vote for Trump either let's look
at one other one this is David Saburo
it's from oh Claire Wisconsin my name is
David Silva Ravitch and they also call
me solo I live just south of Eau Claire
Wisconsin I love the community I love
the scenery the one thing I really like
to do most is to go out of the
snowmobile water cross-cancel
national championship they race
snowmobiles across water it is amazing
they just go fast enough where they
don't sink but sometimes they do and
that's fun today I work for a plumbing
and heating company in 2016 I backed
Trump because he wasn't a politician and
that to me made him look kind of like me
or a lot of other people that want
things done in the country but it seemed
like now that he's in office he's right
in there with them being all crazy he
definitely thinks he's above the law
maybe that's because he's a businessman
if I could go back three years I would
say just think it over a little bit
harder in 2016 I voted for President
Trump but not this time a B PAC is
responsible for the content
this ad these are the types of ads that
could really pull people who are unsure
the diehards it won't matter but you
don't need to convince the diehards it
was just 75,000 in three states take the
stigma out of changing your mind
changing your mind can be portrayed in
politics as flip-flopping negatively or
it can be doing the adult thing owning
your mistakes when you have more
information you come to a different
conclusion and doing the right thing
this time around is the way that I would
frame it and of course you know the
die-hard Trumpets will say the people
featured in these ads are fake former
Trumpets they were never for Trump all
of that stuff doesn't matter because 62%
of the trumpets are never going to
reconsider their support of Donald Trump
this is meant to appeal to the 38% of
Trumpets who are get a bull they're not
in the I'm with them no matter what camp
and it could make a difference in 2020 I
think that this is a good ad a good ad
campaign let me know what you think I
will remind you we are getting closer to
Thanksgiving 2019 we are going to be on
maybe Thanksgiving Day maybe Black
Friday I'm not sure yet we are going to
be doing our last major membership drive
promo of the year if you want to sign up
for a membership at an obscenely
discounted rate I mean it's it's it's so
low low low low priced that I can't even
say it because I don't even know why I
just can't that's the story I'm telling
you today anyway if you want to be
notified about just like the best
membership deal of the year on either
Thanksgiving Day or the day after get on
our newsletter at david pakman.com takes
a second to sign up you will be notified
on whichever day we decide to send it
out Thanksgiving maybe the day after of
this obscene membership special and I
will gladly welcome your support at that
hugely discounted rate get on our
newsletter at david pakman.com make sure
to follow me on Twitter at des Pakman we
will take a quick break and come back
with much more right after this